hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt's eine yogurette fr torte
etwas yogurette ist ich kann doch auch
nichts ein echt hast du schon mal
gegessen
ja und zwar schmecken yogurette richtig
lecker nachsommer finde ich die haben ja
seine musik sie hier
das ist ja so vollmilch schokolade
vollmilchschokolade regel mit einer jahr
sonne joghurt creme und erdbeeren und
genauso habe ich die torte aufgebaut
ich habe nämlich im inneren schoko
biscuit böden habe eine joghurt creme
und dann noch erdbeeren
das heißt dies nicht nominiert so
schmeckt auch noch schmeckt auch nach
yogurette und jeweils zu mir genau und
ich zeige euch jetzt zuerst einmal was
wir alles an zutaten benötigen
ich habe jetzt bereits einen wiener
boden vorgebacken und zwar ist sein
dunkler wiener boden also mit
kakaopulver und werde dazu jetzt eine
leckere joghurt creme zubereitet an
zutaten brauche ich 100 gramm
puderzucker 500 gramm naturjoghurt der
hat 35 prozent fettanteil 250 gramm
magerquark 400 milliliter sahne seiner
part 2 päckchen ak tine 300 gramm
erdbeeren und 100 milliliter wasser
ich werde zuerst einmal den wiener boden
durch schreibt den habe ich es gestern
bereits vorgebacken so lässt es sich
einfach besser durchschneiden den
schneide ich jetzt zweimal durch dann
habe ich drei bilden
den boden setzt sich jetzt direkt auf
eine tortenplatte und zidan die zwei
oberen deckel ab und da kommt direkt
einen tollen rahmen es joghurt ist er in
der konsistenz nicht so ganz fest wie zb
quark oder wie sahne
deswegen finde ich joghurt immer ganz
gerne auch mit etwas engagement dafür
muss jetzt die ak tine mit dem wasser
aufkochen und lasst sie dann zwei
minuten sprudelnd kochen und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
sahne mit vier teelöffel mit seiner
partei schlagen
jetzt kann ich bereits den quark in die
russen geben das geht natürlich auch
alles mit einem handrührgerät da kommt
noch der joghurt mit dazu und der
puderzucker sarahs bruder drücke dann
verliere ich die zutaten ganz kurz
miteinander
um den geschmack abzurunden gebe ich
noch ein spritzer zitronensaft rein was
auch gut passen würde wäre limetten bis
und jetzt gebe ich zwei bis drei
esslöffel von dieser quark joghurt masse
mit routine rein muss das kurz berühren
so kommt diarra tine auf temperatur wird
also etwas abgekühlt und dann kommt die
mischung direktmandat mit zum joghurt
und so passiert dann eben nicht dass ihr
irgendwie studierte kleine stückchen mit
in der creme habt jetzt gut verrühren
die mischung das jetzt ganz kurz stehen
und werde in der zwischenzeit schon mal
die ersten würfe
die
ich habe die erdbeeren sind 1 cm würfel
geschnitten ich habe jetzt im alligator
gemacht aber natürlich könnt ihr auch
einfach mit dem messer zu sprechen
jetzt kommen die direkt mit indem man
kurz untergehoben
und jetzt habe ich direkt noch die sonne
unter und dann ist sie joghurt creme
schon fertig
jetzt will ich die hälfte der sahne
creme direkt auf den ersten tortenboden
dann wird es glatt verstrichen und diese
erdball stückchen sehen eben jetzt so
aus wie in der yogurette dann kommt der
zweite top jetzt einfach den deckel
genommen denn das mittlere stückes immer
ganz schön gerade und jetzt kommt die
restliche creme mit rein und wird dann
mit dem decken abgedeckt
jetzt kommt da ein drauf und dann muss
die torte für mindestens 4 stunden in
den kühlschrank
am besten natürlich über nacht dann
könnt ihr die torte nämlich am tag
vorher schon zu bereiten
und dann geht es direkt an die deko die
torte sitzt schön kalt und jetzt muss er
noch dekoriert werden
ich habe dafür zwar noch ein paar schöne
erdbeeren 200 gramm sahne etwas salat
und natürlich yogurette ich werde zuerst
einmal die sahne steif schlagen mit zwei
teelöffeln salat
jetzt kann ich direkt den torten rahmen
lösen
jetzt streppel streiche ich die
oberfläche der torte mit sahne und die
torte wird dann umhüllt von yogurette
mit einem torten einteiler die torte
markieren drückt sie leicht an
jetzt kommt direkt die yogurette riegel
außen herum
nee
nie
die erdbeer nehme ich jetzt unterhalb
ihres sieht des grünen das jetzt hier
dran
und jetzt kommen die erdbeeren direkt
hier an den rand
jetzt nehme ich noch ein paar yogurette
riegel und schneidet sie etwas klein und
die kommen doch dann noch als dekoration
drauf
die
nur das problem dass sie eine regel zu
viel ausgepackt habe ich muss leider
vernichten
problem gelöst jetzt kleine torte
serbien hat gesehen was ich gemacht er
hat dieses ding gemacht dieses kamera
aber richtig die torte sitz fertigen
kann angeschnitten werden und mord und
sanierer etive probieren
ich mag zuerst ich bin groß geworden ich
habe übrigens die torte diesmal in 14
stücke eingeteilt also die hat einen
durchmesser von 26 zentimetern und bei
zwölf stücken geht es mit dem judo
retter außen nicht auf das heißt ich
habe 14 stücke gemacht wer bei den
torten einteiler genommen und dann ist
es immer so dass immer genau ein
tortenstück drei yogurette stückl am
rand hat wenn das so ausgerastet habe
noch eine geometrie machen muss ist auch
das darfst du nicht die hand genommen
ich habe es gesehen und jetzt hat man
hier im inneren sowie in den yogurette
stückchen auch eben diese erbstücke mit
dabei ich meine das ist natürlich eine
kleine kalorienbombe
denn man hat ja nicht nur das
tortenstück sondern auch noch drei
yogurette stücke darf der papa die torte
probieren bitte komm papa darf die torte
probieren und tut das turbulente stück
samira aber nicht alle drei essen 1
reicht und
also mit luftig locker und richtig
geschmeckt nachhaltig geschwächt und die
uhr witten definitiv und das finde ich
cool finden wenn du ein problem hast die
wie das produkt heißt aber auch so
schmeckt ja nicht nur garniert ist
informativ also wird danach machen oder
wenn du packen könnte die banken dürfte
ich das mache ich
und falls ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht es mit bloc täter stets noch
mal ganz genau und ich wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß beim nachhaken und ich denke
man kann es auch ganz gut mit den
anderen yogurette sorten machen weiß
limette diese sommer edition ist ab und
zu mal gibt beispiele schmeckt wie
akkurat und nirgendwo ist die uhr edt
ungeschminkt sagen milchschnitte joker
das habe ich noch nicht gegessen kann
ich mir probiert es mit genau wie also
nach meinen 21 produkt also viel spaß
beim nachbacken